sadly the health experts and the biden
administration do not appear capable
of providing clear and consistent
guidance on anything
it's here it's there it's everywhere
it's flipping and flopping and flailing
all over the place
and people rightly are getting angry and
they feel like
they don't know this is the gang they
can't shoot straight they don't know
what they're doing
last week the white house urged
employers and local governments
to enact strict vaccine mandates
wow i didn't think that was going to
happen but it did
now major teachers unions oh
interestingly they're coming out against
those mandates
all of a sudden it's not exactly totally
clear
where the bite administration stands on
the issue of course democrats every
election season
they rake in millions and millions of
dollars from teachers unions
donate enough money you can even dictate
cdc policy as we have learned previously
make no mistake vaccine mandates are a
terrible idea
just like vaccine passports is frankly
an affront to the principles of medical
privacy
your medical privacy matters doctor
patient confidentiality
that also matters and i have said many
times on this program
please take coven seriously please do
your own research please take into
account your unique medical history
your current medical condition please
consult with your doctor or doctors or
medical
professionals that you trust and then
based on that
information that only you really know
about and your doctor really know about
then you have then you should make an
intelligent decision for yourself and
your family
and loved ones in europe for example
look what's happening
people of france they're not allowed to
make their own decisions
look at your screen the french
government is now mandating vaccine
passports nationwide
that has caused widespread protests and
rioting
back in the u.s mass mandates are now
becoming you know coming back in city
after city even for vaccinated people
apparently if you're a well-known
democrat though the rules don't apply to
you
because after announcing a brand new
indoor mask mandate in washington d.c
even if you're vaccinated mayor bowser
celebrated her birthday
not following her own mandate as you can
see pictured their mask-free
with comedian dave chappelle's pretty
funny guy she also attended an indoor
wedding with hundreds of guests
and again i don't see a mass there
either just like the democrats from
texas flying on that private jet
to you know cause the democrats to end
the filibuster as they themselves were
filibustering
because she's a democrat don't worry
fake news cnn
she will get a free pass take a look
i don't know what do you think i get it
well uh you know i it's hard for me to
remember what we're all supposed to be
angry about because it wasn't that long
ago
where we were criticizing politicians
for wearing masks
still where the science was telling them
oh
they didn't need to be you know yeah i
mean i look at the photo and i see it
it seems like it could be during the
toast right everyone's heads are pointed
in a certain direction it seems like
maybe they
are listening to someone is what it
appears to to me
now while bowser enjoyed a mastery
weekend after a mass mandate
well barack obama get this you're going
to love this he's planning a
birthday blowout super spreader event
for himself
at his mansion in martha's vineyard with
a reported guest list you got it
of 700 plus people somehow my invitation
i think got lost in the mail
but circle back press secretary gensaki
doesn't seem at all concerned
take a look is president obama
setting the wrong example about how
serious coba 19 is
by hosting a big birthday party with
hundreds of people this week
well i would certainly refer you to the
team who is working for my former boss
to give you more
specifics vaccinated people can still
spread
this delta variant around so is there
concern that this
president obama birthday party might
become a super spreader event well i
think peter
the guidance is about what steps people
can take
when they're in public settings people
who are watching this at home and they
see well
president obama can have a party with
several hundred people should they think
that it is okay for them to have a party
with
several hundred people now well we
certainly advise everyone to follow
public health guidelines
which i know the former president who is
a huge advocate of getting vaccinated
of following the guidance of public
health experts would certainly advocate
for himself as well
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else